and he comes over to talk to anthony
davis he's got blood on anthony davis
shirt
andreas looks over and said hold up he
got blood on your shirt anthony davis i
love his attitude he looks like
this ain't the only one i got chill let
me coach this young fella
not rattled at all but that's leadership
that is flat out leadership and being
engaged even though
you're not in uniform he's got video on
his
phone that's ipad
what's wrong with you man that's an ipad
i don't have an ipad that's a massive
phone
yeah i didn't realize see if i was mark
right now i'd be trying to say yeah look
like a phone
you know but you're right that was
that's terrible on my part
can you imagine getting blood on your
your clothes though if it was anthony
davis
like i'm gonna say this kuzma may have
done him a favor
the people of texas they
the empathy they have for their
neighbors
and their communities i couldn't be more
impressed
i couldn't be more proud to live
in the great city of houston a lot of
talent is going to be
in the building kevin durant not playing
a third shirt wow
this set i wonder if he had someone
bring it from home
because you can't think coming to a home
game you've got
three different shirts no that's that's
his career high in shirts
well the second shirt was a laker golf
shirt a polo shirt
but if he had that already here he would
have gone to that immediately
that's a good point he had someone bring
it
from home streuse too strong on the
three-pointer harrell tips of the lebron
james
what's your career high ensues well on
every road trip as horton
talon horton hits the three i would say
i would say i come every road trip no
matter how long it is
with one multiple shirts one suit
horton tucker with that three there you
go
i was like all over the place i don't
think
hyphenated names should be allowed
either okay that's another
you're either horn or tucker but not
both